Speaker 1: We are going to hear from some
Speaker 2: folks in the audience.
Speaker 1: We take calls now via Discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
It's great to hear what is on people's
minds. Why don't we start today with Chris
from Texas? Chris from Texas? What's going on?
Speaker 4: Hey David, this is Chris from Texas.
How are you doing? I mean, never mind about that.
Speaker 1: I'm doing well. Thank you.
Speaker 4: I guess one thing I'm wondering is
that, like with Biden, I mean, I know some people
are wanting Bernie to run again, but I don't
agree with that because of the fact that like,
I love Bernie with all my heart,
but I feel that with Bernie
after losing twice, I think it's just going
to make him look bad. And I think it will hurt
the progressive movement overall for him to run
again, just because it'll make us look as if we
are not willing to cooperate with the Democrats.
Speaker 1: I don't think it's
about cooperation at all, but
Speaker 2: I agree with you. I think that
Speaker 1: as a combination of Bernie Bernie's
failed runs so far as well as Bernie's age,
Speaker 2: I
Speaker 1: some people might be furious with me,
but I think the window of opportunity for Bernie
has closed. First and foremost, if Joe Biden
runs again, Bernie is not going to beat him in a
primary. So that already makes us look at 2028.
And yeah, I just I just don't see it. I think it's
unrealistic. If somebody wants to change my mind,
you can try, but I just don't see it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I guess. I'm guess. I'm
just also worried also about the future as well.
Like with Biden's approval ratings going down,
I kind of want him to do other things
like maybe do another UBI and potentially
also potentially also doing something along the
lines of like maybe being more forgiving on the
student loan debt. Wait a second, hold on.
Speaker 1: When you say, do another UBI,
do you mean a COVID stimulus check?
Speaker 4: I mean, that's probably on my
list worries, but I feel like I'd be more willing
for him to do something along the lines of like
maybe extending student loan forgiveness or maybe
giving students maybe at least 40 something off at
least ten thousand dollars student loan debt?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I have to tell you,
I agree with those things. I want him
Speaker 2: to do those things.
Speaker 1: I never believe that those were things
Joe Biden was going to do when he was running,
and he seems to have no interest in doing them.
I just don't think he's going to do them now.
Should we? Should we pressure? Of course.
I mean, this is what activism is for, but
I don't think he ever had any interest in doing
those things. But I think the point were maybe
kind of converging on is the left
needs some kind of the progressive left
Speaker 2: needs a charismatic
Speaker 1: leader within the Democratic Party.
Speaker 2: I don't think it's Bernie.
Speaker 1: Is it AOC? I don't know. I
think it's too early to say. But I
do think that a charismatic leader
is needed in the progressive left.
Speaker 4: I do feel like AOC would
be a good candidate, but I feel like one
problem that she has that she's only been
her highest level of being elected is only
the House of Representatives. I feel like
she would either need to at least maybe challenge
someone like, what's her name again, Gillibrand or
or or Hochul for a state level position.
Speaker 1: OK, that's fair.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, there will be time
Speaker 1: to look at that, but it sounds
like you and I are mostly on the same page.
Speaker 4: One last question I have, though,
to, I guess, considering I'm kind of
a little scared about the Republicans
Speaker 2: potentially getting back to
Speaker 4: the Senate in Senate and House in 2022.
Yeah. Why isn't Joe Biden or any of the Democrats
with their their power right now try to admit D.C.
and Puerto Rico a states, and so we can at least
give us some way of a buffer from preventing
the Republicans from gaining more seats again?
Speaker 1: I love the idea. Joe Biden doesn't
just doesn't seem interested. It just
doesn't seem a priority. Now remembered,
you know, D.C. would almost certainly be two
Democratic senators. Puerto Rico is a little
bit more of a question mark. Puerto Rico's more
conservative than some people think. On balance,
it would still be great for the Democratic Party,
but Biden just doesn't seem interested in that.
Speaker 4: Yeah, but we would get at least around
seven seats in that, both in the in Congress.
Speaker 1: At least that sounds about right.
Yeah, that sounds about right. I would love
to see it. I think they should be states.
Speaker 2: I don't believe it will happen
before 2024.
Speaker 4:
OK. All right, thank you for the call, David.
Speaker 1: All right, my pleasure. Again.
Thanks, Chris. Appreciate hearing from you.
Good questions. Specific good questions.
Let's go next to Jason from
Huntsville, Alabama. What's
happening in Alabama these days?
Speaker 4: Yes,
I still don't understand how anyone.
Speaker 1: Jason, from Alabama, you're
on the air and it sounds like
you're on another call there.
Speaker 4: You I look to Huntsville that
first started. Listening to some kind of show,
Speaker 1: Jason, did you want to talk to me
or are you just watching TV? I don't know.
Speaker 4: Then this just went on and on.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, that's too bad.